Коли нарешті закінчиться карантин? Коли відкриються школи, магазини і перукарні?
Які обмеження скасують або послаблять першими?
Уже тепер очевидно, що повернення до звичного життя не відбудеться в один день.
Євросоюз офіційно визначив три критерії для послаблення карантину:
це суттєве сповільнення поширення коронавірусу, достатня дієздатність системи охорони здоров’я
та можливості епідеміологічного нагляду й моніторингу.
Кожен уряд діятиме індивідуально залежно від ситуації в межах своєї країни.
Перше пом'якшення карантинних заходів у ФРН почне діяти з 20 квітня.
Дозволено відкритися магазинам площею до 800 квадратних метрів,
а також незалежно від розміру автосалонам, книжковим та велокрамницям.
Власники магазинів мають забезпечити відповідні умови гігієни
і не допускати скупчення покупців.
Громадянам настійливо рекомендують носити захисні маски
у громадському транспорті та в крамницях.
Але обов’язку носіння масок не запровадили, оскільки цей товар у Німеччині й досі в дефіциті.
Надалі залишатимуться закритими кафе, ресторани і бари.
Як і раніше, заборонено зібрання у церквах, мечетях і синагогах.
Готелі зможуть працювати тільки для тих, хто у відрядженні, туристам не можна.
Перукарні зможуть відкритися з 4 травня за умови
використання засобів індивідуального захисту.
Школи поетапно почнуть відновлювати свою роботу теж з 4 травня.
Виняток планують зробити лише для цьогорічних випускників шкіл,
аби забезпечити їм підготовку до випускних іспитів, які відбудуться у другій половині травня.
За словами польського міністра охорони здоров’я,
вже з наступного тижня країна почне поступово "розморожувати" економіку.
Зокрема дозволять працювати більшій частині підприємств.
Крім того, мають пом’якшити обмеження для відвідування магазинів.
Наразі у Польщі до крамниць можуть увійти тільки втричі більше покупців, ніж є відкритих кас.
Зміна полягатиме у тому, що кількість покупців визначатиметься залежно від площі магазину.
Головне правило - забезпечити відстань між покупцями в два метри.
З деякими обмеженнями мають відкритися також салони краси та перукарні.
Ця країна стала першою в ЄС, яка вже відкрила дошкільні заклади
та початкову школу після місячного карантину.
Уряд королівства, спираючись на успіхи в подоланні епідемії коронавірусу,
відновлює роботу шкіл для учнів з першого по п'ятий клас включно, а також ясел і дитсадків.
Для цього розробили нові правила безпеки, що передбачають
дотримання дистанції та норм гігієни.
Зокрема школи мають забезпечити відстань у два метри між партами в класах.
Учні середньої та старшої школи продовжать дистанційне заняття
і повернуться до класів лише 10 травня.
А от торговельні центри, перукарні та масажні салони відкривати поки не будуть.
Так само як і бари, ресторани і дискотеки.
Данцям, як і раніше, заборонено збиратися групами понад 10 осіб.
А в сусідній Швеції досі так і не запроваджено жорстких карантинних обмежень.
Тут залишаються відкритими ресторани, кафе, школи і дитячі садочки.
Заборонені, по суті, лише зібрання понад 50 осіб, а також відвідини будинків літніх людей.
Уряд країни апелює до свідомості громадян, щоб вони
добровільно обмежили свої соціальні контакти і дотримувалися дистанції у громадських місцях.
Офіційний Стокгольм вважає, що загальна ізоляція призведе до ще гірших наслідків,
ніж ситуація з коронавірусом.
Австрія вже цього тижня пом'якшила карантинні захо ди.
За словами австрійського канцлера, треба подолати цю кризу якомога швидше
і в економічному плані.
Вже відновлено роботу будівельних і садових магазинів,
а також невеликих крамниць площею до 400 квадратних метрів.
Решта магазинів, торговельні центри та перукарні зможуть відновити роботу з 1 травня.
Готелі та ресторани будуть закриті, щонайменше, до середини травня,
а всі масові заходи скасовані до кінця червня.
У крамницях та інших громадських місцях громадян зобов'язали
носити захисні маски, які громадянам роздають на вході.
Уряд розробив план виходу з карантину в 5 етапів.
З 20 квітня відкриються, зокрема, фермерські ринки,
майстерні, а також дозволять весілля до 10 осіб.
Потім за тиждень відкриються магазини площею до 200 квадратних метрів.
І лише з 25 травня - перукарні, а також музеї та галереї.
Завершальний етап заплановано на 8 червня, коли запрацюють
усі заклади в торгових центрах, готелі, театри, а також туристичні маршрути.
Крім того, чехам дозволено виїжджати за кордон -
у відрядження або щоб провідати родину.
Але за умови, що після повернення вони підуть на 14-денний карантин.
Ці країни ЄС найбільше потерпають від коронавірусу.
У Франції суворі карантинні обмеження продовжили до середини травня.
Натомість в Італії вже є часткове послаблення.
Дозволено відкритись книжковим магазинам, крамницям дитячого одягу та деяким іншим.
В Іспанії теж головні обмежувальні заходи залишаються в силі
з незначними послабленнями.
Дозволили відновити роботу будівельним фірмам,
а також окремим промисловим підприємствам, які не відносяться до критичної інфраструктури.